max scherzer
two and two
ninth career start against milwaukee
with a 2-2-9 era well you know him well
fastball up to 98-99 miles per hour at
time or when needed the wipeout slider
an excellent changeup
that's in a shift
and the big curve ball
he pulls out almost the entire arsenal
and the kick in the pitch swinging
attacker back to the mount shows her has
it he'll throw to second one and mercer
will hold on to it no chance to double
up yelich at first bobby garcia nobody
swinging the bat better right now than
garcia the month of may has been
spectacular for him
garcia had a first inning home run in
game one of the double header yesterday
is only hit in the twin bill
and this one hit a ton center field all
the way back and gone
a two out two run home run
for garcia
and the brewers strike first against max
scherzer javi garcia for the second time
in his many days has hit a first inning
two run homer
yeah another big bat swinging a miss
on 96.
brandon woodruff on the hill for
milwaukee yeah outstanding his last time
out of winning against the padres at
american family field seven innings
three hits no runs
making start number three against the
nationals he's currently 2-0 he's only
allowed two in runs
strike three call
there's your first doubt turner shaking
his head but woodruff needed the
strikeout and came up with it
and called strike three outside edge
this time so woodruff got the inside and
the outside and that at bat to bell
soto on the move throw is on target
scherzer over the hand the kick in the
pitch swinging a drive to right center
stevenson back still back warning track
makes a running catch and slams into the
fence and holds on
andrew stevenson with a jam in center
swaying and a miss on a big slider
[Applause]
back shurster takes care of him and very
short
three two coming
struck him out with a fastball
another strikeout for brandon woodruff
that's three in a row
you're the idea man though colts strike
three
and woodruff gets another one four
strikeouts here through two
one and two
oh that's not fair strikeout number five
first time around they go one for eight
with the home run in the wall a long
hold by max
[Music]
and this one high towering to right
center
juan soto's under it
this ball grounded to josh harrison
outfield grass so garcia will lead off
next to them
falling two strikes to stevenson
and he waves at strike three as narvaez
applies the tag
a broken matt dribbler long nice play
for the out
and this one wong spins
and there's the out vintage colton wong
right there
mercer stays with it
long time shortstop play in the hot
corner that was a very good play
55 runs for the m's
he gets jammed on that one
on his way in soto cruising to it
playing in the ship josh harrison is way
out there as well the 2-2 to shaw
swinging a fly ball shallow center
stevenson broke back mercer going out in
the back pedal and the third baseman
makes the catch
here's the delivery
strike three swinging as woodruff gets
another
swinging strike three and woodruff a
very quick fourth inning one two three
scherzer is over the head into the wide
end of pitch
swing and a miss
adamus down on strikes and max
as crank out number six
and the brewers have a bunch of lefties
at the bottom of the order that's a
curveball for the strikeout gomes will
step out to a throwing lane
and now max with number seven
that's pain
and that's number eight for max
[Applause]
leading off the bottom of the fifth
o2
he did come back fastball and struck him
out anyway
8th inning rally
and this one caught out there by wong
nice job
3-1 on the way
this one driven to center field
jackie bradley jr a few steps in front
of the wall for the final out
and the big train over matches the bay
third time up
and how about a curveball for a taken
strike three
and now from actual sir 101
times
with 10 strikeouts or more
all right brandon woodruff back out on
the hill for milwaukee to call him our
own and jordy mercer is going to walk
away
three and two
sam holbrook's little gunko
he did his strikeout call ron if it's
out there again you better be swinging
davey martinez up on the rail or that's
kevin long pardon me
and maybe kevin's been tossed
so a big spot for josh bell who has
struck out twice
here's his pitch
change up hit in the air left field line
yelich gives it a chase he's there makes
the catch in fair territory and the
inning is over six shot out innings from
brandon woodruff and he strands a couple
of nationals the bases have been walked
loaded craig council is going to send
brandon woodruff to the plate had a baby
here it is
swinging a fly ball to left field
schwarber toward the line ranging in
he'll cross into foul ground and make
the catch as we go to the bottom of the
seventh inning brandon woodruff
is back out there for the crew
[Applause]
right into the shift
and one down
harrison fly ball right field garcia
he's there and he makes the catch the o2
to gomes
and a fly ball to right
playable for garcia he's there and he
makes the catch and how about seven
shutout again
from brandon woodruff here this
afternoon
narvaez
drew a walk in the seventh inning over
two otherwise
[Music]
right field to the wall
and gone a home run garba is number four
on the season how about that for an
insurance run here in the ninth to make
it a three-nothing game
this one slapped to left field right at
christian yellings and there's the final
out of the ball game as the brewers win
it